slowly methodically they search for
booby traps left by retreating russian
forces
this ukrainian demining team tells us
the russians have hidden explosives in
consumer electronic devices such as
mobile phones and laptops and spread
them all around
this car was abandoned by the russians
the ukrainians say it was full of looted
electronics
we are looking for mines and other
devices including unexploded devices
ammunition left behind by the russian
troops
we are trying to prevent anyone who
comes back here from being injured in
this area the russian animals look what
they did
here barely a few meters of this town
remain untouched by battle
the russians used heavy artillery and
rockets and missiles all throughout
european you see sites like this scenes
of heavy artillery shelling there is
almost near complete destruction in
places within arapeen this place was
incredibly important to the russians if
they'd taken this town it would have
been a staging post for any potential
attack into the capital kiev
bosses are still taking the last
remaining civilians out of town these
people had no choice but to remain they
had nowhere else to go
others are returning to a village on the
outskirts they have no idea what awaits
them other than the destruction of what
was once their homes and lives
inside of peen however residents are not
allowed to come back as security forces
sweep the town
before the war this was a bustling
commuter town of around 70 000 people
today it's become a symbol of ukrainian
resistance the town that fought back
president vladimir putin says russian
forces are not targeting civilians or
civilian infrastructure but once again
these pictures contradict those words
we won't know for a while how many
people have been killed but early
estimates from the mayor's office
suggest 200 to 300 with many more
injured
we won't know for sure because the
bodies of some of the dead remain under
rubble and may well be there for some
time imran khan al jazeera